que lentement parce les heures comme
passe un enterrement tu pleureras
l'heure où tu pleures qui passera trop
vite mans comme passe toutes les heures
j'écoute les bruits de la ville est
prisonnier sans horizon je ne vois rien
qu'un ciel hostile et les urnes eu de ma
prison le jour s'en va voici que brûle
une lampe dans la prison nous sommes
seuls dans ma cellule belle aux cartes
et cher réseau guillaume apollinaire
1913 génériques
[Musique]
salut à tous cette émission s'adresse à
toutes les personnes détenues au
personnel pénitentiaire mais aussi à
tous ceux qui sont confinés dans leurs
maisons ou dans leur appartement
on pense à vous dans les murs sommaire
[Applaudissements]
et qui récite jean de la fontaine
un chef deux étoiles thierry marx un
ténor du barreau maître temime les
conseils sportifs de côté benzema un
live signé akhenaton l'écrivain leila
kilani et un message personel venue de
floride signé booba
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
s'écrie vous les avez certainement
entendu si vous êtes près d'une prison
on va en parler tout de suite avec un
directeur le directeur de la prison de
la santé je vais tout de suite la plaie
par skype c'est bruno clément peytremann
bonjour bonjour merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous merci d'avoir pris le temps de
répondre pour des confiné vous allez
bien écoutez ça va comme le directeur
d'un établissement pénitentiaire en
période de treize inédite de crise
sanitaire
c'est compliqué et on s'efface
[Applaudissements]
ses cris de détenus qu'on vient
d'entendre et de passer dans l'émission
vous les avez entendu vous aussi à la
prison de la santé
on l'a pas entendu dans les mêmes
proportions mais le jour où on a décidé
le confinement général est que nous
avons annoncé la suspension des parois
on a eu nous aussi un mouvement de
protestation des dd qui sont restés sur
les cours de promenade pendant plusieurs
heures
qu'est ce qui se passe derrière vos murs
est ce que vous diriez monsieur que la
situation est explosive
non je la qualifierais pas d'explosifs
je la qualifierais tendu c'est difficile
mais elle n'est pas explosive à la santé
en tout cas pour plusieurs raisons
d'abord parce que avec l'aide des
autorités judiciaire parisienne
nous avons considérablement diminuer le
nombre de détenus avant même les
annonces du gouvernement dans le cadre
de la loi d'urgence sanitaire puisque le
premier jour du confinement on était à
850 détenus et ce matin on a démarré la
journée à 720 vous voyez en moins de
quinze jours on a libéré sans troupe des
+100 comme des sept ce sont des détenus
en fin de peine c'est ça oui ce sont des
détenus dont la sortie était proche qui
bénéficient de remises de peine
exceptionnelle pour que la sortie arrive
maintenant pendant cette période de
confinement ou des gens qui étaient dans
l'étang de la libération conditionnelle
et pour lesquels le fait d'avoir un
hébergement suffit à ce qu'on leur
octroie la libération quotidienne donc
ça c'est le premier point qui lui
faisait quand même très avantageux ici
le deuxième point c'est que c'est un
établissement qui est neuf qui a fermé
ses portes pendant cinq ans de 2014 et
2019 et dans les conditions de détention
sont quand même tout à fait bonnes et
notamment pour affronter une crise
sanitaire
alors qu'on sait que les problèmes
d'hygiène sont très importants alors on
va faire le tableau sanitaire il ya des
cas de co vide à la prison de la santé
alors depuis le début de l'épidémie on a
recensé quatre cas de détenus qui ont
été testés positifs au co vide
un été un a été libéré ce matin et
placés en confinement chez lui donc il
nous reste à ce jour trois malades et un
détenu pour lequel nous attendons les
résultats du test
vous parlez de test ça veut dire que
vous en avez vous pouvez tester tous les
prisonniers alors on teste tous les
détenus pour lesquels il ya des signes
cliniques d'equihen cycliques qui
apparaît on les connaît un fièvre toux
courbatures etc
les médecins de l'établissement qui sont
un service qui relève de l'hôpital
cochin test les détenus sur place envoie
le test à cochin et on a généralement
les résultats dans les 24 heures et
parmi le personnel pénitentiaire il ya
aussi des quatre co vite parmi le
personnel pénitentiaire actuellement
menacées ce cas qui sont recensés alors
quand on dit c'est ce qu'a s'est passé
ce cas qui ont été testés ces seize cas
pour lesquels le médecin a dit ce sont
les signes du coc vite donc vous restez
chez vous on en a deux qui ont été
testés qui sont positifs alors il vous
reste donc quelques cas encore dans les
murs qui sont testés positifs dont le
rappeur est magique et je crois dans ces
cas là comment ça se passe
où est-ce qu'ils vont ceux qui sont
testés positifs alors bon on a identifié
en lien avec les autorités médicales de
l'état mission nous avons identifié un
secteur qui est un sac était un secteur
qu'on n'avait pas encore ouvert qui
était vite de détenus et on a décidé
d'affecter la les détenus malades et les
détenus en test en attendant le résultat
du test qui quitteront ce secteur si
jamais ils sont négatifs
eux sont confinés complètement pendant
24 heures en attendant les résultats du
test et les détenus malades ne peuvent
sortir en promenade puisque ont été
reconnus comme étant malade c'est quoi
le confinement
quand on est déjà enfermé et ja est ce
que l'enfermement est le confinement
c'est la même chose non l'enfermement et
le confinement c'est pas du tout la même
chose l'enfermement c'est la privation
de liberté et si on prend la formule du
président giscard d'estaing 74
lorsqu'ils visitent les prisons de lyon
il dit la privation la prison c'est la
privation
tu es et rien d'autre ça veut dire qu'à
côté de ça on peut avoir tout un tas
d'activités orienté sur la prise en
charge du détenu sur la réinsertion du
travail de la formation professionnelle
beaucoup d'activités socioculturelles du
sport etc
ça c'est l'enfermement aujourd'hui on
est dans une situation de confinement
c'est à dire que ces activités qui
viennent réduire les effets des
socialisante d'incarcération elles sont
suspendues
donc là on est dans une situation de
confinement est la seule activité qu'on
propose aujourd'hui aux personnes
détenues c'est la promenade avère une
avec la fin des parloirs c'est quand
même l'augmentation du stress de
l'agacement de l'inquiétude est donc de
la violence alors il n'y a pas
d'augmentation de la violence on n'a pas
constaté ça nous au contraire il ya un
effet de d'abord il ya un effet de
sidération
c'est à dire que c'est moi j'ai 30 ans
de carrière c'est la première fois que
l'administration pénitentiaire prend la
décision de suspendre les parloirs
donc on est quand même dans une
situation qui est inédite
inwi est jamais vu il ya un effet de
sidération
il ya eu un effet de contestation pour
vous aussi bien sûr pour nos psys les
parloirs sait on touche pas au parloir
les parloirs c'est le maintien des liens
familiaux
c'est l' équilibre de la détention donc
le premier le premier réflexe ou la
première conséquence est plutôt un effet
de sidération et après il ya aussi un
effet d'angoise mais un effet d'envoi ce
qui est train l'ensemble des français
aujourd'hui et l'ensemble même du monde
entier qui est j'ai peur pour mes
proches j'ai peur pour moi les gens
posent beaucoup de questions c'est pour
ça que aujourd'hui je pense que nous à
la santé on tient le choc
parce que à l'instar de ce qui se passe
dans beaucoup d'établissements
pénitentiaires
on communique énormément avec nos
personnels évidemment mais aussi avec
les personnes détenues tout à l'heure je
citais en ouverture des missions
apollinaire qui est passé par les verts
de la santé il a écrit l'extrait du
poème que j'ai dû tout à leur extrait
d'alcool et je vois derrière vous
un autre artiste sept jours stramare des
clashs d'être rock'n'roll monsieur le
directeur
oui enfin je sais pas si on peut dire
que rock'n'roll mais en tout cas c'est
ma passion et puis joe strummer est
quelqu'un de justement profondément
humain et en plus la fiche que vous avez
derrière moi c'est la fiche d'un film
qui a été consacrée à cet artiste dont
le titre et ce futur iphone ce qui veut
dire en anglais que le futur n'est pas
écrit et je pense que ce qu'on vit
actuellement ça nous montre bien que le
futur est pas encore écrit derrière moi
il ya un autre personnage que j'aime
beaucoup qui s'appelle johnny cash alors
bougez vous le montrer parce que c'est
une photo où elle allait c'est juste
avant de rentrer en scène et johnny cash
est un des premiers artistes en 1958 à
avoir joué dans les prisons et il a
notamment enregistré un disque à la
prison de saint quentin en californie et
moi je vous recommande vraiment
l'écoutille de ce qu'il fait avec les
détenus qui à un moment de magie n'est
venu
[Applaudissements]
le 4k droit commun
le speaker espionne uk temps duster
hop
alors là maintenant on a rendez vous
avec un député de la république qui est
connu pour avoir déversé une tonne
d'oignons sur le parking d'un
hypermarché et qui va nous réciter une
fable de jean de la fontaine pourquoi on
lui demande bonjour richard ramos
bonjour c'est quoi cette histoire d'une
tonne d'oignons sur le parking d'un
hypermarché vous avez pas peur d'aller
en prison vous non on a toujours peur de
ces endroits de privation de liberté
mais il faut même les combats qu'on a
amené alors dites-nous c'est quoi cette
histoire ce groupe de députés qui va
lire des fables de la fontaine louis
avant que 8,19 on a monté un petit
groupe de députés on est en train
d'apprendre les fables de la fontaine et
on avait en projet au printemps ce sera
remis d'aller compter dans les prisons
françaises
et ça avec des députés de tous les bords
politiques donc oui c'est un sujet c'est
la prison le ccc le maillon le plus
faible de notre république donc cantonné
un député de la république qu'il faut
aller défendre les maillons les plus
faibles donc donc celui de la prison
salut je défend ardemment la culture
populaire
je pense qu'il faut revenir à la culture
populaire je suis né dans le quartier et
c'est ça qui élèvent des esprits et donc
la prison elle n'est pas qu'une punition
elle est aussi reconstruire des hommes
et des femmes et reconstruire est
désormais une femme ça se fait aussi
pour amener la culture là où peut-être
un peu moins pourquoi les fables de la
fontaine
d'abord parce que la fontaine il ya
presque tous dans la fontaine vous voyez
bien que il ya la morale il ya la poésie
ya le rythme et donc quand on lit la
fontaine ça nous emmène dans les
profondeurs de nous-mêmes et peut-être
de temps en temps dans les profondeurs
de la société erronée relisez le meunier
voilà donc la fontaine ya presque tous
dedans
[Applaudissements]
on vous écoute richard ramos à nous
n'avez que les eaux et la peau tant les
chiens faisait bonne garde
seul ou rencontre un dogue aussi
puissant que hbo gras poly qui s'était
fourvoyé par les gardes l'attaqué le
maître en quartiers si elle ou lui fait
volontiers mais il fallait livrer
bataille et le matin était de taille à
se défendent hardiment le loup donc
laborde humblement entrant propos et lui
fait compliments sur son embonpoint
qu'il admire
il ne tiendra qu'à vous beaussire lui
reparti le chien quitter les bois vous
ferez bien vos pareils sont misérables
cancre air est pauvre diable on à
condition et de mourir de faim karkwa
rien assuré point de franchir ip tout à
la pointe de l'épée
suivez moi vous aurez un bien meilleur
destin
le lourd prix que me fera t-il
rien ou presque rien dit le chien donner
la chasse aux gens portant bâton et
mendiants flatter ceux du logis à son
maître complaire moyennant quoi votre
salaire ce rapport ce relief de toutes
les façons os de poulet aux deux pigeons
sans parler de man caresse le loup déjà
se forge d'une félicité qu'il fait
pleurer de tendresse je me faisant il
vit le col du chien pelé qu'elle cela
lui dit il
car quoi rien que deux choses le collier
dont je suis attaché de ce que vous
voyez est peut être la cause
attachez dit le loup vous ne pourrez
donc pas vous voulez non mais qu'importe
il importe si bien que de tous vos repas
je ne veux en aucune sorte
cela dit m louh s'enfuit libre mais
court encore
merci beaucoup elle est magnifique est
ce que la morale de l'histoire la morale
de la fable c'est que la liberté ce
n'est pas confortable
la liberté c'est s'est jamais
confortable liberté c'est pour ça que
j'ai choisi est allé inconfortable il
n'y a pas plus haut que la liberté donc
construisons nous sur la liberté voilà
on peut aller à des facilités parfois je
dirais presque même des petits larcins
mais la liberté n'a pas de prix c'est ce
que je dis là la femme
merci beaucoup richard ramos merci
infiniment vraiment on va rester avec
avec une de vos collègues à l'assemblée
nationale elle a quelque chose à vous
dire
[Applaudissements]
bonjour je m'appelle taiwan qui va je
suis député des yvelines pour la
république en marche et je préside la
commission des lois à l'assemblée
nationale depuis trois ans la commission
des lois travail sur la question de la
détention
moi même j'ai été visitées plus d'une
trentaine d'établissements
pénitentiaires et à chaque fois je vais
visiter un espace que je trouve très
important qui s'appelle la bibliothèque
vous le connaissez bien vous le
fréquenter vous allez lire apprendre
découvrir
j'ai voulu aujourd'hui vous faire
partager un livre que j'ai beaucoup aimé
il s'agit de la longue route de bernard
moitessier ce livre raconte une aventure
humaine celle de bernard motté sié qui a
participé à la première course autour du
monde à la voile en solitaire sans
escale et en autonomie de cette aventure
humaine il en a tiré un journal de bord
où il raconte son vécu ses aventures ses
mésaventures lorsque son bateau chavire
il raconte sa symbiose progressive avec
la nature avec les animaux avec les
oiseaux avec les dauphins avec les
animaux marins avec les tempêtes la
lumière le soleil bref nous vivons avec
lui ce tour du monde à la voile et ce
qui m'a particulièrement plu dans cet
ouvrage c'est que au moment où il doit
achever ce tour du monde au moment où il
doit remonter dans l'atlantique pour
franchir la ligne d'arrivée et on sait
qu'il est probablement le premier à
pouvoir le faire
eh bien il renonce il change d'avis et
il décide de continuer son tour du monde
de ne pas finir cette course et de ne
pas franchir cette ligne d'arrivée en
vainqueur
parce que pour lui en fait en faisant
cette course il a découvert autre chose
il a découvert il s'est découvert lui il
la découvre
r la nature il a je pense trouver un
sens à sa vie et le sens à sa vie ça
n'est pas de franchir cette ligne
d'arrivée donc voilà j'ai trouvé que cet
ouvrage était absolument passionnant
absolument fascinant j'espère qu'il en
sera de même pour vous casques bleus au
liban deux étoiles au michelin le chef
thierry marx est un homme qui croit à la
deuxième chance il a d'ailleurs déjà
plusieurs fois était dans différentes
centrales pour donner des cours de
cuisine aux personnes détenues il va ici
nous expliquer comment on cuisine en
prison car oui en prison on cuisine en
cellule
[Applaudissements]
bonjour thierry marx alors cuisiner en
détention on peut le faire bien sûr j'ai
pris comme chaque détenu reçoit une
liste de cantinage donc j'ai utilisé le
même matériel qu'on peut retrouver en
détention c'est pas très compliqué il
faut bien sûr prendre le temps de le
faire mais c'est réalisable et puis
mangé ses plaisirs bien-être santé
donc on va commencer par un petit chose
que j'aime bien faire quand je travaille
avec des personnes qui sont privées de
liberté à base de farine de maïs un
petit pain une galette qui peut se
garder trois ou quatre jours alors on
connait tous la boîte de maïs avec le
grand bonhomme vert dessus ça va très
très bien voilà attention pas trop de
sel parce que c'est des produits en
général qui ont déjà été qui ont déjà
été salée jaune d'oeuf farine on va
garder les blancs d'oeuf
comment certains m'ont tout mélange là
on a jaune d'oeuf et le maïs
maintenant je vais prendre la farine de
maïs et je vais en mettre 4 cuillères de
3,4 s'aperçoit que c'est des cuillères
bien pleine qui mélange on voit ça effet
si un petit peu trois beaux tours de
moulin à poivre
je connais tous cette astuce avec
l'amicale pour monter les blancs d'oeuf
j'ai mis une petite pierre à l'intérieur
que j'ai bien nettoyer ou une bille si
on a une bille ça marche aussi très bien
pour la mayonnaise
[Applaudissements]
voilà les blancs sont montés je fais
attention ne pas perdre à l'adie dedans
voilà ma préparation est prête feu moyen
un peu d'huile
j'ai récupéré un roux en plastique
résistant à la chaleur
ça on le jette pas si on peut le mettre
dans une salade on peut laisser sécher
temps de cuisson environ 3 minutes de
chaque côté thermostat 3 pour fonction
de la puissance de votre plaque
si vous voulez les garder longtemps vous
pousser à 5-6 minutes de cuisson
toujours pareil voilà pour les petits
pains farines de maïs il à danser le mia
plus d'une fois en prison avec iam il
est allé jouer pour les détenus et pour
les personnels de la pénitentiaire
le conseil de lecture signé akhenaton
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors mon conseil lecture c'est un livre
en deux tomes magnifique des joj kawa
qui s'appelle musashi lapierre le sabre
est la parfaite lumière c'est l'histoire
d'un samouraï et comme tous les amoureux
de cette époque-là au japon et parcourez
le pays pour pour se battre pour tuer
d'autres samouraï et inscrire son nom
tout en haut de l'affiché ça parlait de
réputation de célébrités de tuer des
gens et un jour y hills à coude sur le
pont de gau jour que ton un matin il
voit là il voit la rivière qui s'écoule
les arbres qui s'agitent le vent qui
passe dans les arbres les montagnes
illuminée par le soleil et il dit je
suis en vie ce livre là m'a inspiré
l'écriture de mon album solo en 2015 qui
s'appelle je suis en vie et qui m'a fait
réaliser que des choses très simples
dans la vie sont les choses les plus
importantes
bah non évidemment il n'ya pas que les
livres dans la vie à la musique aussi
partout tout le temps pour tout le monde
ah oui
ah oui on a un live toutes les semaines
aujourd'hui akhenaton
[Applaudissements]
dans les moments compliqués convient et
qui doivent être encore plus compliqué
pour vous toutes et vous tous et pour le
personnel pénitentiaire
je voudrais vous adresser un petit
cadeau un couple et deux morceaux qu'on
appelle grand rêve grande boîte parce
que pour moi la dimension du rêve est
très importante et encore plus dans les
moments difficiles comme ceux que nous
vivons
ma caravane passe
les tocards rêve d'arracher la joie de
vivre à coups de tokarev sauf si pour
eux tout ça s'écrit n'entrer en bas du
chèque pour se payer une grosse
cylindrée
les soucis qui vont avec la peur du
destin insipide comme la conscience tout
ça ce n'est toi paul liquide
ces regards noirs j'étais au lit sur les
supports et que les plaques de peau
séché au coude qui l'école
si ce n'était que les élèves en cours
qui déconne les fondations des reins
plonge au coeur des écoles quelques
profs ont glorifié mes défaites
l'immense majorité ranger mes ambitions
prier dans une boîte d'allumettes est
talonné de 0 à 20 ma vie une série de
filles leur nous à la fin leurs
prédictions sur mon futur destiné aux
cabannes elle ne valait pas mieux que
celle de paco rabanne à tous ceux qui
jugeaient que le rap était notre passade
l os et moi même où la rafale je garde
encore mes délires d'ado trente ans
après aucune et greenpeace comme à pau
sans courte échelle pour le nirvana on y
va par nos propres moyens
et tant pis si je chute en chemin chaque
jour est une grande at on met les grands
rêves dans les grandes boîtes le présent
nous éprouve pourquoi marché est basse
le soleil brille pour tous et jamais ne
s'efface on m'a trop d'idées changé que
je mettais mon avenir en danger leurs
boniments dans des grands sacs
j'ai mis les grands rêves dans les
grandes boîtes
merci akhenaton
les personnes détenues le connaissent
bien j'ai dit lui mais ça peut être elle
elle porte cette personne généralement
une robe noire elle n'est pas toujours
d'ailleurs de leur côté nous avons la
chance d'être avec un ténor du barreau
bonjour maître temime bonjour dans des
jeux va soir dans la fontaine de la
concorde alors maître temime
comment allez vous eh bien écoutez ça va
pour l'instant ça va est ce que le
confinement se passe bien
formidable puis totalement seul donc en
paix avec moi même
en tout cas il a l'air de vous mettre le
sourire puis je rigole beaucoup j'ai eu
la chance d'avoir des amis
drôle et plein d'humour le gouvernement
a annoncé la sortie de quelques 5000
détenus est ce que c'est assez sont des
aménagements de fin de peine on précise
bien sûr qu'il ne s'agit jamais ni de
terroristes ni de violence faite aux
femmes
ça suffit 5000 écouter à mon avis ça
suffit pas
ça suffit pas parce que je sais bien que
déjà ces libérations suscite des
critiques bnl ans suscite des deux côtés
nous on est très nombreux à considérer
est pas du tout des gens laxiste qui
sont inconscients droits de l'hommistes
face d'ailleurs ce qui n'est pas une
insulte on est on est très nombreux à
considérer il ya d'ailleurs des recours
qui sont faits devant concède est en ce
sens que c'est totalement insuffisant
que c'est déjà un effort mais qu'au lieu
de se contenter de libérer des détenus à
qui il reste deux mois de prison il
faudrait aller vers des délais plus
important de l'ordre de 6 mois avec
évidemment un examen individuel de
chacun de ces cas et puis je vous dis il
ya quelque chose qui là ne se décrète
pas mais qui est la détention provisoire
je trouve ça aberrant que
le nombre des détentions pollueurs ne ne
chute pas considérablement à l'occasion
cette épidémie est ce que ça veut dire
mettre que après cette crise dans la
praye kozhin si les ténors et même ceux
qui sont pas droits de l'hommistes 10
il faut arrêter avec les détentions
provisoires qu'il faudra que la garde
des sceaux s'en saisissent et qui est
une évolution vrai cette fois ci pour le
coup il ya une règle avec laquelle où on
est élevé quand on est un jeune juriste
puis un jeune avocat c'est que la
détention provisoire doit être
l'exception et bien il faut que cette
règle soit effectivement respectées et
que la détention provisoire soit
l'exception sino il n'y a aucune autre
manière de respecter un peu mieux qu'on
le fait c'est à dire très mal la planque
son innocence je vous ai demandé m e
temime de réfléchir à un livre et vous
avez choisi celui d'un grand avocat
bah j'ai choisi le livre un livre de
robert badinter qui s'appelle
l'exécution ce livre a été déterminant
j'en ai encore en mémoire des passages
entiers
il est sorti en 1973 et il a fait suite
à la condamnation à mort d'un d'un
accusé qui a défendu robert badinter
avec philippe lemay et donc je crois que
cette exécution parce qu'il a été
condamné et non graciée cette exécution
de de claude bontemps et t on pas à
l'origine a été déterminant dans le
combat qu ensuite robert badinter va
venir en tant qu'avocat contre la peine
de mort et qui va avoir le destin étant
parfois incroyable qui va avoir
l'honneur de porter en tant pis de l'alu
6 devant le parlement français
un dernier mot maître temime quand on
est en prison
est-ce qu'on est hors de la société non
non on n'est pas hors de la société on
est hors du monde
ddd d'aider des gens libres mais on est
dans la société
on éteint un être humain qui a
absolument tous les attributs de tout
citoyen non on fait partie de la société
pour moi on fait totalement partie de la
société
et il faut pas du tout porté sur les
gens qui sont détenus un regard
distancié méprisant étrangers ils font
partie des nôtres et pas seulement parce
qu'ils sont des êtres humains mais aussi
parce qu'ils sont des citoyens à part
entière
je vous souhaite bon courage pour la
confiance en m ben vous aussi merci
journée et bon courage
merci beaucoup m à tamines merci
infiniment je sais qu est ce qui va
suivre va vous intéresser les grandes
problématiques du confinement
c'est la prise de poids comment rester
fit quand on est en cellule et qu'on ne
peut pas bouger
un coach de classe mondiale mesdames et
messieurs karim benzema
[Applaudissements]
on sait pas de combien c'est difficile
pour tout le monde ont mené là c'est
difficile pour nous
son président m concours et que je vais
vous laisser un peu de démocratie
libérale
il a fallu et ça vous en faire un peu
d'ordre placer ma chaise quand un
tremblement de 40 secondes quand vous il
faut ça pour bien bien bien bien l'art
la gc ca après faut laisser les veaux il
ya comme ça il ya comme ça y'a comme le
grand chimie din al amal 4 à l'autre
d'être passé
un peu ouvrir une auberge tacle limite
en diagonale d autres ya plein de choses
à faire bon voilà c'est du bruit il ya
aussi les abords normal je laisse le
droit d'exercice je suis la meilleure
pratique tac tic tac bien souffler
celui-là donc voilà et après après ce
que vous plaire on peut faire ce lavier
ça vous savez le colisée
voilà près force mentale voilà quelques
forces
on y voit un message de paul vous
l'apprendre que ça à la bouche quand ça
vous a vu dans ces cas là je vais
rappeler la présente la santé maintenant
on va parler un surveillant
il s'appelle aurélien pruvost et il est
je prends mon papier premier surveillant
pénitentiaire frappe unsa bonjour
aurélien bonjour merci d'être avec nous
dites moi c'est quoi premier surveillant
ben c'est le premier grade d'encadrement
où on est cher comparé ça en fait un
chef d'equipe tout simplement
[Applaudissements]
évidemment les surveillants vous n'êtes
pas confiné vous faites partie des
professions essentiel effectivement on
n'a pas le choix on ne met pas les
justiciables dehors le soir ni la
journée donc ils sont ils sont eux-mêmes
confiner la prison dans la prison
actuellement et des personnels il faut
qu'on assure le minimum qui est la gare
et puis sur le continuer à faire la
distribution du repas leur autoriser la
seule activité que à laquelle ils ont
annoncé qu'ils aient la promenade
actuellement et la justice ne s'arrête
pas et elle continue de vivre en fait au
ralenti mais elle continue de vivre
dites-moi aurélien est ce que cette
période de confinement à l'intérieur de
l'enfermement créer une
je sais pas peut-être une solidarité ou
une fraternité particulière entre les
personnels pénitentiaires et les
personnes dès qu on va dire que ça
permet peut-être de renouer le dialogue
sur certaines sur certains aspects quand
on attend maintenant il il ya une
tension mais la tension est les paliers
assure un rapport de force ça n'est pas
dû aux rapports de force elle est lié à
l'anxiété que chacun peut développer ou
pas par rapport à par rapport au virus
mais au contraire c'est des moments
privilégiés de pouvoir rediscuter de la
population pénale est entre autres avec
les annonces qui ont été faites sur la
facilité de pouvoir accéder à une
libération pour les fans mais nous les
traiterons open il ya des questions qui
se posent et puis des chacun essaye
d'apporter des réponses à l'autre et
vous avez des masques
alors il ya le personnel qui au contact
de la population pénale a accès aux
masques alors les détenues noront au
pacs dont n'ont pas accès aux masques il
ya aussi une raison de sécurité et qu'il
faut qu'on puisse les identifier en
permanence tout simplement qu'on les
confonde pas avec du personnel ou des
intervenants civils qui pourrait être là
il ya beaucoup de dialogue depuis depuis
le confinement en fait avec la
population pénale ou avant même que le
confinement est commencé et on a incité
on a développé le dialogue sur les sur
tout ce qui était gestes barrières et
c'est vrai que là il ya des gestes
professionnels
on a été un peu obligé d'arrêter dans
des gestes sécuritaire
tout simplement pour limiter la
contagion c'est quoi un geste
sécuritaire ça va être par exemple la
palpation de sécurité qu'on a arrêté
pour éviter le transport du virus d'une
personne à l'autre qui pourraient
potentiellement se faire donc ce type de
geste ou ou compact le départ on a été
obligé de les stopper
aussi bien pour la sécurité des uns et
des autres personnels comme les nus mais
aussi parce que bon on n'est pas encore
de toute personne qui pourraient être
porteuses du virus à avec la fin des
parloirs c'est aussi la fin de
l'approvisionnement au site on sait que
les détenus fume pour à peu près 80%
ça va devenir un problème au tgp alger
ce côté pataud d'entrée du produit
stupéfiant dans les établissements c'est
après de vous dire qu'il y en a pas ça
serait ça serait mentir
maintenant j'aurais tendance à dire
n'importe quelle personne qui est
toxicomane ou addict à une substance
vous lui retirer à terme ça crée des
crispations et forcément en a rentré ses
questions on a effectivement la question
elle va se poser un moment donné il y en
a qui risque effectivement d'être un peu
plus tendue ça sera à nous et ensemble
et collectivement de trouver des
solutions on pourra pas résoudre
on n'est pas magicien mais la question
se posera un moment donné pour certaines
pour certaines personnes détenues oui
merci de votre réponse allait franche ça
fait plaisir ça vous fait plaisir qu'on
parle de vous et aurélien enfin de vous
du personnel pénitentiaire je pense que
c'est quelque chose qui est
effectivement attendu depuis le début de
cette situation qui est attendu par
l'ensemble du personnel quel que soit le
corps quel que soit le grade parce
qu'effectivement on a souvent tendance à
nous oublier
et c'est vrai que
une profession qui fait pas forcément
rêver à la base mais on n'y vient pas
forcément par choix mais par contre
c'est une profession qu'on apprend à
aimer et effectivement c'est sûr pense
que c'est important à un moment donné de
de parler de cette profession qui est
peu commune parce que c'est pas donné à
tout le monde de de surveiller des êtres
humains
merci beaucoup un grand merci je vais
parler à quelqu'un que vous connaissez
peut-être
elle s'appelle marie pierre lac à rabat
tout à fait oui oui et elle s'occupe de
l'association lire pour en sortir merci
infiniment merci bien
j'en ai avoué avoir à vous aussi bonjour
marie pierre bonjour alors comme les
activités et les parloirs sont
supprimées il reste pas grand chose mais
il reste la lecture est cette semaine à
la santé l'association lire pour en
sortir a mis en place une nouveauté vous
nous expliquer ce que c'est que ces
boîtes à livres alors les boîtes de
lecture en fait c'est un pays dont on
avait parlé des pêches à trentels
semaine avec le directeur de la prison
de la santé avec ça dit keith adjointe à
savoir installer des boîtes à lire dans
les cours de promenade et le la personne
détenue ou de promenade
elle peut aller retirer des lignes dans
ces boîtes à venir marie-pierre je vais
préciser quand vous dites nous c'est la
saulire pour en sortir qui promeut la
lecture et qui permet par la lecture de
réduire sa peine alors dites nous quels
sont les livres qui plaisent le plus
alors damman il ya des gens de venir
il pèse plus particulièrement aux
personnes détenues et le tour de mes
livres
on a organisé grâce à deux textes sans
frontières tient compte aussi des
centres d'intérêt de nos lecteurs
alors ce qu'elle affectionne
particulièrement les personnes détenues
sont les bandes dessinées à cale bébé
qu'elle bébé alors le numéro un de notre
catalogue de lecture c'est la bande
dessinée de berthet one qui s'appelle
l'évasion voilà nous avons aussi l'arabe
du futur et de riad sattouf bien sûr
voilà donc ça ils vont décider c'est
effectivement ce qui est facile c'est
accessible
vous savez qui c'est pas facile de lire
dans une cellule gars aussi même de
concentration
souvent les personnes docu sont
plusieurs dans l'est dont les cellules
et c'est vrai que la bande dessinée
c'est un bon format à la fois adapté au
contexte est aussi une bonne accroche
sont des personnes qui se remettent à
lire un livre en prison nombreux
témoignages que nous avons on se remet
aussi à vie en prison à
grâce à ses activités près d'autres que
nous venons ensuite c'est à personne
cette infection aussi beaucoup d'acteurs
c'est tout ce qui est biographie tout ce
qui permet aux personnes détenues de
s'identifier
nelson mandela évidemment nelson mandela
grand corps malade au nom de rosa park
voilà donc tout ce qui est on là tu as
eu un fils de zinedine zidane qui vont
porter aussi bien sûr qu'il épouse qui
était aussi très très publicité les
romans qui explique tout ce qui tourne
autour de la spiritualité du bien-être
voilà l'un d'eux qui s'en faudrait de de
matthieu ricard tous ces livres autour
de la spiritualité aussi un rencontre
aussi un vif un vif succès auprès des
lecteurs des peluches dans votre
catalogue de livres proposés dans
l'association dire pour en sortir qu
elle est le numéro 1 celui qui plaît le
plus alors il ya 2 litres ex-aequo parce
que notre catalogue de lecture on leur
fait en le renouvelle tous les deux ans
alors je dirais quelqu'un qui hors
compétition parce qu'il est dans le
catalogue des lectures depuis la
création d'association depuis 2015 et
c'est le petit prince de saint-exupéry
je vous le montre voilà un ca si le
catalogue de lecture qui nous permet de
mettre en place un programme individuel
et d'accompagnement à la lecture donc le
petit prince demi est présent dans notre
catalogue depuis 2014 depuis qu'une 15
cm un bar one et ensuite il est
désormais ex-aequo avec la bande
dessinée dont je vous ai parlé la bande
ici de berthet one pour que pertes et
c'est un artiste c'était une personne
qui est passé par la case détention et
effectivement la lecture et la reprise
en détention en france en mai sa vie
puisqu'il est devenu p des cinéastes et
il a écrit à louer témoignant de son
parcours et de son expérience en
détention qui s'appelle l'état ions
et bien sûr c est le number one maison
et dvi on l'a mis dans le catalogue
alors marc et pierre je vais peut-être
en profiter pour dire que avec l'air
pour en sortir
vous proposez aux familles de faire le
lien
je me tourne vers nous parce que les
familles ou les amis des détenus comme
les parloirs sont suspendus je reviens
marc et pierre comme les parloirs sont
suspendus vous n'avez plus moyen de voir
vos famille ou vos amis
alors on vous propose avec lire pour en
sortir de nous envoyer vos tweets vos
messages vos vidéos vos dessins ce que
vous voulez vous pouvez l'adresser
l'adresse vous dit si je me trompe à
marie-pierre l'adresse cd confinement at
lire pour en sortir point org
déconfinement à lire pour en sortir
point org
ils vont recevoir tous les messages et
puis vous nous les transmettre et
vacquières tout à fait en élimant ravir
aussi boîte aux lettres et de maintien
des liens amicaux et vidéos avec les
gens qui sont en détention c'est
extrêmement important dans cette période
merci beaucoup merci infiniment bon
pourra pas tous les passés mais on fera
au mieux
merci marc et pierre la cia très bientôt
en voir c'est un beau roman c'est une
belle histoire je vous chante ça mais
parce que la séquence s'appelle cet
abonnement on va pas chanter on va lire
on va demander chaque semaine un
écrivain de choisir un grand livre qui
raconte l'enfermement la liberté lier le
souffle là prêts et cette semaine la
personne qui va nous lire un extrait
nous expliquer pourquoi c'est leïla
slimani
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui je voulais
vous parler d'un de mes livres de chevet
un livre que j'aime énormément que j'ai
découvert quand j'étais adolescente et
ça s'appelle les braves gens ne courent
pas les rues de flannery o'connor donc
ce livre est un recueil de nouvelles il
a été écrit par ou faladié o'connor qui
est une écrivaine du sud des états unis
qui a toujours vécu dans une dans une
ferme et c'est un recueil de petites
nouvelles qui raconte à la fois
l'histoire de personnages tout à fait
ordinaire des personnages qui sont
souvent un peu à la marge de la société
qui ont du mal à s'intégrer sont des
nouvelles assez noir un peu pessimiste
sur la société américaine et même je
tairai sur sur la nature humaine mais ce
qui est très très beau dans ce livre
c'est l'évocation de des lieux
l'évocation des paysages ce sud des
états unis qui est marqué par bien sûr
la ségrégation raciale par la violence
par des rapports assez conflictuelle
aussi entre les hommes et les femmes
entre les différentes classes sociales
les ouvriers ou bien évidemment les
noirs qui sortent de deûle esclavage
c'est un livre très très très marquant
il ya des personnages qu'on oublie
vraiment jamais le personnage du
polonais le personnage du philosophe
boiteux le personnage de l'évangéliste
par exemple et c'est vraiment un livre
qui est comme un voyage on est plongé
complètement ailleurs dans un autre
monde dans une dans une amérique qui est
à la fois réel et en même temps un peu
fantasmée et c'est très agréable à lire
aussi parce que comme ce sont des
nouvelles on peut les déguster les unes
après les autres y revenir de temps en
temps la relire et on en a une autre on
en a une autre vision quand on y revient
donc voilà c'est un livre que je vous
conseille vraiment chaleureusement ça
s'appelle les braves gens ne courent pas
les rues de flannery o'connor
on va parler de télévision maintenant
parce que depuis la fin des parloirs
dans toutes les prisons les télés sont
gratuites je sais qu'à la santé il ya
une télé par cellule et la télévision
qu'on soit enfermé ou confinées voire
les deux c'est toujours une fenêtre sur
le monde alors on va revenir sur des
grandes archives de belz archives de la
télévision et on vous propose pour cette
première une interview de georges
simenon ça se pouvait pas mieux faire
c'est d'en apostrophes et c'est un grand
moment de télé
[Applaudissements]
les maigret vous les écrivais
directement à la machine à huy
directement à la machine jésus-christ
petit flotteur ou presque mais vraiment
vous siffle ti en écrivant les maigret
oui parce que c'était face et il ne va
ce devenu un petit peu plus visible à la
fin parce que j'ai un peu confondu les
maigret les autres néo roman j'allais
plus loin dans mes personnages mais dans
les premiers dans mon mettons dans les
30 premiers c'était un amusement même à
la fin d'ailleurs jeune écrivain maigret
que quand j'étais fatigué comme j'ai
besoin d'écrire mais je n'avais pas la
force physique ne me mettra roman parce
que vous savez c'est simplement d'une
forêt une résistance physique très forte
en deux heures et demie écrire un
chapitre de 20 pages dactylographiées
c'est fatigant à des vrais romans tandis
que les meilleurs pianoter qu'est ce que
vous appelez c'est fatigant
intellectuellement non c'est fatigant
mais physiquement mais vous savez
intellectuellement non je ne suis pas
intelligent de 7,7 sortir ce qu'on a
tous ceux qui sont là on a dans le coeur
se sortir son instinct je suis un
instinctif je ne suis pas du tout un
intellectuel je n'ai jamais pensé un
moment j'ai senti on
je n'ai jamais pensé un personnage j'ai
senti un personnel ni va je n'ai jamais
inventé une situation la situation est
venue lorsque j'écris un roman mais je
ne savais pas du tout où mon personnage
allait mener celui mené et je vivais
pendant d'abord 11 jours et puis à la
fin un set dans la peau de personnages
avons dit à un jour et c'est parce que
jean-marie vos livres souvent aveyron
chapitre et puis les derniers ont eu
neuf chapitres puis sept chapitres
exactement et sabrina je n'avais plus la
force de vivre 11 jours dans l'état où
j'étais nous parlions de ma région tout
à l'heure eh bien lorsque je commençais
à romans dès le deuxième jour atteint
mari je me disais didon en personal doit
être vierge ou en tout cas un type qui
part heureux et quelle mauvaise santé
disait pourquoi dis parce que tu marches
maintenant comme ça tout à coup tout cas
l'air
pas vivre avec nous là tout à fait
grognon etc
elle devinait mes personnages d'après
mon identité parce que toute la journée
je restais mon personnage principal et
cette histoire qu'on a raconté qu'il
peut être une légende que vous portiez
toujours la même chemise que vous
écriviez c'est à dire en tongs
j'avais deux chemises que je vais
acheter des à dire mon arrivée à new
york était très pratique parce que les
manger très large des chemises à
carreaux en écossais rouge et l'autre
n'est que ces mondes et ses chemises à
maints avantages d'être très très saoul
est bien absorbé la transpiration je ne
la sentais pas coulé sur ma peau parce
que je sortais en argent d'un chapitre
de roman toujours jeune et changer
complètement gtb la même chemise
montréal avaient tous les jours si je
vous entends bien quand vous écriviez
quand vous étiez un roman comme vous
dites vous perdiez du point 800 grammes
par jour
teresa fait l'expérience et la pesée
tous mes vêtements comme quand je
sortais de mon temps de remonter je me
déshabille entièrement je me doucher et
je me changerait elle a pesé mais
vêtements et sous-vêtements avant et
après bien le résultat c'est cette
recette à 800 grammes par jour
beaucoup aimé les maigret même s'ils
sont souvent très inégaux mais c'est
c'est assez agréable de se dire que
quand on met un maigret que de retrouver
le même personnage avec ses qualités ses
défauts sa placidité ça
son mutisme parfois et d'en trouver
finalement en train de résoudre l'énigme
ce qui est important dingue
dans maigret et j'en suis dans la raison
c'est l'énigme sens et digbeu le livre
n'aurait pas beaucoup d'intérêt
alors je trouve qu'ils se dévalue un peu
en parlant de composition de semis
littérature
moi je trouve que c'est finalement comme
le lecteur quand il y avait grève ne
possédât semi littérature de littérature
ou autre chose
simplement il prend du plaisir et c'est
formidable quand on a aimé un livre on
en parlait mais c'est exactement ce que
font les bêtes qui sont à la santé ils
sont lus par françois xavier demaison
paroles de l'ombre
[Applaudissements]
paris la santé le 9 mai 2019 si
seulement le mot pouvait suffire
perdu dans mes pensées et dans mes
souvenirs
c'est avec le coeur serré et beaucoup
d'émotion que j'écris ces mots nous
n'aurait pu imaginer qu'une telle
épreuve puisse se transformer en une
expérience humaine si enrichissante
si en son genre au surprenant que cela
puisse paraître
j'ai eu beaucoup de chance durant ce
périple et ce grâce avant vous qui
m'avait tant apporté humainement et qui
est devenue ma famille au sein de ce
lieu que vous avez transformé en oasis
au milieu de ce désert carcéral bien
plus qu'un travail
la bibliothèque est devenue un lieu
d'évasion quotidien qui m'a permis de
surmonter toutes les craintes et
contraintes auxquelles j'ai pu être
exposé durant mon séjour entre ses murs
vous m'avez tellement tous apporté que
je ne peux m'empêcher de ressentir de la
tristesse et une certaine mélancolie
il m'est dû retrouver les bons mots pour
exprimer ce que je ressens vraiment
lorsqu'on m'a recruté pour devenir
auxiliaire bibliothèque
je m'attendais pas à vivre autant de
bons moments blasé voire effrayé je
voulais simplement travailler pour ne
pas avoir à rester enfermés ainsi fuir
une réalité brute et parfois sauvage que
peut-être la détention
surtout lorsqu'on ne connaît pas les
codes que l'on ne veut pas s'y soumettre
la bibliothèque m'en faire bien plus que
ce que je pouvais espérer une oasis je
pouvais être moi même où j'ai rencontré
des êtres exceptionnels
alors s'il n'avait qu'un mot à dire ce
serait merci merci de m'avoir maintenu
en vie et d'avoir été ma source
d'énergie en ma détention
merci beaucoup le mois de la fin
il nous emmène de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique en floride
[Applaudissements]
bonjour booba bonjour ça claque ou pas
j'ai trop contente de vous à voir
comment ça se passe les confinements à
miami ça se passe très bien mais ça se
passe ouais ça se passe bien bas on fait
attention
je suis avec mes enfants ils font leurs
devoirs
je leur fais faire un peu de sport le
confinement est ce que c'est comme
l'enfermement ou est-ce que ça n'a rien
à voir vous avez connu les deux bons
soit oui sauf que en prison on est privé
de liberté confinait on a on a la
possibilité de sortir si on veut mais
c'est très déconseillé mais l'on en soit
c'est un peu la même chose et vous
arrivez imaginer le confinement dans
l'enfermement on en a parlé tout à
l'heure avec le directeur de la prison
de la santé
ça c'est compliqué c'est à dire ne pas
sortir en promenade ne pas aller aux
morts etc
bah ouais bah pour le coup bon ont
rejoint ce que tout le monde lui en ce
moment
enfin ceux qui respectent le confinement
ya pas de sortie du tout le sport passé
en cellule dans sa maison donc oui je le
conçois est-ce que booba la culture ça
aide à tenir en prison
la culture je pense que c'est 2 en
prison en dehors de la prison en prison
je pense que c'est très important
d'une parce que j'allais raconter c'est
qu'on a fait des bêtises
donc c'est l'occasion de s'instruire et
peut-être de se former à un métier de
reprendre les cours et au delà de ça
surtout ça occupe de la musique lire un
courrier et cuisiner tous à sao que
booba vous c'est surtout sur la musique
que vous vous êtes appuyé j'étais en
prison
ouais voilà mais la musique m'a beaucoup
aidé sa main mon premier album je
l'écris en prison et voilà la la la la
la musique ça permet de voyager de de
sortir de sa cellule
puisque la colle des sous c'est très
fort leur musique c'est vrai ça rappelle
des souvenirs c'est vrai que c'est
toujours lié à des moments très précis
ou d'une époque des souvenirs dépend des
situations
est-ce que ça fera un titre le
confinement vois ça pourrait donner une
chanson ces 19e jeux se manquer le
morceau que vous auriez aimé écrire
mistral gagnant
pourquoi ah ba aujourd'hui parce que
j'ai une fille mais parce que ce morceau
là quand je parlais tout à l'heure de
s'évader à travers la musique quand
j'écoute ce morceau là demain soir sur
mon banc son unité avec toi j'ai
vraiment l'impression d'être sur le banc
mais vraiment chaque parole j'ai
l'impression de l'avoir et c'est un peu
c'est un peu ça aussi qui me qui
m'inspire quand j'écris c'est très
visuel très cinématographique graphique
et quand j'écoute de morceaux vraiment
j'ai l'impression d'être à côté de
renault et sa petite fille est d'être au
bout du mans et de les regarder du coin
de l'oeil comme ça et de les observer
tu vois les pigeons les flingues drôle
et les rires qui déservent les murs vous
avez publié cette semaine sur facebook
une vidéo à propos du gorna times c'est
franchement il n'ya pas d'autres mots un
engagement civique que vous portez le
civisme booba c'est important bien sûr
surtout en des temps surtout en dans des
situations comme comme celle du corps
d'un virus là c'est vraiment le moment
de servir à quelque chose
voilà on entre guillemets je me compare
pas à une infirmière un docteur pompiers
nous on a vraiment entre guillemets
l'occasion de sauver des vies par le
message qu'on transmet qu'est ce que
vous dites à tous ceux qui vous
attaquent ils écoutent et qui peuvent
eux qui grâce à agra sa grâce à
l'émission va rester chez lui il voit
pas choper le corona et elle va pas
rentrer chez lui et le et le transmettre
à ses parents bah c'est déjà une
victoire
home doctor qu'est ce que vous répondez
à ceux qui ne nous attendent pas là bas
wall comme welcome to corona times et
puis c'est même pas le débat qui
m'attendent qui m'attendent pas en tout
cas on est là on est là et on va faire
ce qu'on peut pour aider
alors on va le dire l'émission elle va
continuer vous en avez fait une vous
allez faire en deuxième et peut-être une
troisième et puis peut-être voilà y'a
juste de ce qu'on éradique ce de
virus si je peux absolument
un dernier mot booba pour tous ceux qui
sont derrière les murs quelles que
soient les murs ou que soient les murs
et quelles que soient les gens tous ceux
qui sont derrière les murs bas essayer
de garder le moral prenez soin de votre
l'un des vôtres record de vitamine c et
c pour booster votre système immunitaire
fête du sport
prenez soin de vos enfants et voilà
cette attention à vous et surtout restez
chez vous merci bova la piraterie n'est
jamais fini la confiserie n'est jamais
finie en jeu merci beaucoup booba merci
infiniment
aujourd'hui et ben voilà il nous reste à
nous retrouver la semaine prochaine
19h30 le vendredi sur lcp d'ici là vous
pouvez nous revoir en rediffusion ou
alors sur la chaîne youtube de lcp
on se retrouve donc vendredi 19h30 sur
lcp pour des confiné où que l'on soit
dedans ou dehors
[Musique]